-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated performer
and best-selling author
you know from her shows
like "Strangers with Candy"
and "At Home with Amy Sedaris."
You can see her in the second
season of "Girls5eva,"
which is streaming now
on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-Your father and I
walked the devil's path,
and it was a dark one.
-We had no moral compass,
no regard for tomorrow.
Just dopamine, thrills!
-Waking up in a truck bed
beside a civic center,
kind of all wet with, like,
coins all stuck to me.
-[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our dear friend Amy Sedaris!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi! How are you?
-I'm good. Thank you.
Thanks for having me on.
-It's so great to see you again.
-It's really good to see you.
And no jacket. I like this.
-I know!
I got a little more casual
over a pandemic.
Yeah. Yeah, I was like,
"Nothing matters." Yeah.
It's really nice
to have you back.
-Thank you.
-One of the things we --
Why did you bring out a mug,
by the way?
-I'm gonna get you
to sign it later
for an auction I'm doing,
which I'll get to.
-Okay, great. You can feel free
to set it down.
-Okay, okay.
-Okay, great.
-Oh, yeah,
you don't give water here.
Do you have water?
-Yeah, we have water here.
-Oh, look at that jug.
Oh, I see.
Well, you don't want
to fill it up too much,
'cause you're gonna
have to sign it.
-Okay, yeah.
That's a good point.
But, you know,
we've always talked about
how your home is full
of wonderful objects.
-Oh, have we talked about that?
-We have.
-I have been decluttering
like crazy.
-Okay.
-It's been very stressful.
I don't know. Having to say
goodbye to things.
Things I never thought I'd get
rid of, I'm getting rid of.
-Okay.
-Yeah, a lot of anxiety.
I lost 6 pounds doing it.
You know, and I had some friends
helping me, and they were like,
"You know, you have to
make a quick decision.
Are you gonna keep it,
are you gonna get rid of it?"
It's hard.
-And you have some photos
of some of the things. Now, I
think after you gave that setup,
people might be surprised
by some of these items,
because I think no one here
would keep this.
-Really?! What?!
-Well, let's start
with some of your books.
This is a book called
"Asthma and Eczema."
-Yeah, I don't have --
That's a page-turner.
It's really good.
It's a little dry.
Yeah, I'm giving it away.
-You gave it away?
-I'm gonna give it away.
-You're going to give it away.
-The auction is gonna be --
You know Cure Thrift Store?
It's kind of in our
neighborhood, 3rd and 13th.
And we're gonna do
an online auction.
-Oh, great.
-And all the money
goes to diabetes research.
Plus, I'll probably
throw in some rabbit,
you know, places in there.
-Gotcha.
-And then my brother
is doing a --
He has a new book coming out,
and June 2nd, he's doing
an event in Brooklyn.
And I can give away --
I can just give away stuff
on a display table.
So I have three bins of,
like, palm stuff.
Like, a wooden mushroom.
You know, things like that.
-This is another book
that I can imagine.
This one's harder to part with,
because this seems so useful.
-Oh, yeah.
-"Microwave for One."
-Well, I don't have a microwave.
-Well, there you go.
-So that's why
I'm giving that away.
-So it seems
like of all your books,
you got rid of the ones
where you don't have
a microwave, asthma, or eczema.
-You never know,
when guests come over.
-What is this?
Are you getting rid of this?
-Okay, that is
a rusty-nail wind chime
that Todd Ola made for me.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
And it was for people
with bipolar.
You know, that way, when you're
in the upswing, downswing.
It's about crafts for people
with that disability.
So maybe when you're depressed,
you take a handful of nails
and you throw them
in your backyard.
-Okay.
-And then, when spring comes,
you go get those nails,
and they'll have rust on them.
-Okay.
-Which is pretty.
And then you hang them up.
But the problem is now,
with nails, is it galvanized?
Is that how you say it?
They don't rust.
So I had to go on eBay
and get these rusty nails.
-Sorry.
So you went on eBay
and you got pre-rusted nails?
-Yes.
There's a lot of guys
selling rusty nails on eBay.
And I paid $7,
and he sent me a lot.
-Okay, what kind of guy --
When you picture a guy selling
rusty nails, what do you think?
-Ooh. [ Laughs ]
Yeah. You know.
-This is a --
Is this a clipboard?
-Yes!
-Okay.
-The problem with that clipboard
is that it's too long.
You know what I mean?
It's too long for my body.
You know, hold it up,
and it just comes -- You know.
-So the problem is not that it
has a human intestine drawing?
-No.
-Okay.
-I'm gonna get
big bucks for that. Yeah.
-What are these?
-Children's crutches!
Because I have them because --
When people come to my house
and they have kids,
I'm like, "Do you want to play
with the crutches?"
And let me tell you --
Nobody wants to see their kids
playing with crutches.
-Uh-huh.
So, you have these just for --
not for kids who are injured.
You have these for healthy kids.
-To play in.
Yeah, they're playing
with crutches.
-They look like they're
from a bygone era, as well.
-Yeah, they're pretty bad.
-Those are like
"Little Women" crutches.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ] It's so true.
-And now, this is interesting.
Do you think this will move?
-Oh, it says "JEW."
It's the initials of somebody.
Julie Ellen Worden.
-Okay.
-But it says "JEW," so,
hopefully a Jewish person.
-Yeah. Either someone with
those initials or, more likely,
a Jewish person
would be drawn to it.
I also want to ask
about Tina real quick.
-Oh, yes.
-We've talked about your
rabbit, Tina, over the years.
It should be noted, one of
the first times you were on,
you took Tina to the vet,
and Tina was a boy.
-Yes, after four years.
-Okay, so, there's Tina.
-Look at Tina the other day.
Look at that leg.
Yeah. No, Tina, you know,
when I got her, the first --
I did your show,
and I had just gotten Tina.
What is it, 9 years ago
or 10 years ago?
My problem is that people
that watch Tina for me
when I go away on big jobs,
they're moving.
-Oh, no!
-So now I'm really --
I go to bed like this
because I'm worried
I have to find somebody
who can watch Tina for me.
-Is it a lot of work
to rabbit-sit Tina?
-Well, no, most rabbits --
I mean, just in case, you know,
rabbits can get sick like that
because they don't speak
like most animals.
They try to communicate
through their actions.
So I really want someone
who knows about rabbits.
-'Cause your current
babysitter's like, "No."
-Yeah, I met them
at a rabbit conference. Yeah.
-Okay, that's great.
-Which they don't do anymore
in New Rochelle.
-They canceled the --
-Yes!
-You met them at a real
rabbit conference?
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
-But now I speak to them
on "Thump" magazine,
which is another -- Yes.
-You subscribe to "Thump"?
-Yes.
-And people do
look like their --
At rabbit conferences,
when people say,
"Oh, people look
like their animals,"
it's, like,
everybody's got like...
buck teeth.
-There's a carrot bar?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's fun, yeah.
Well, I used to sell stuff,
but they don't buy things.
Rabbit owners don't.
-They don't buy things?
-They're pretty cheap.
-Did you find anything
while you were decluttering
that was too dear to get rid of?
-Lots of stuff, which --
I brought this mug out
'cause you gotta sign this
'cause I can put this in a --
[ Laughter ]
See, I told you!
I'm sorry. Oops!
-Are you sor--
How can you be sorry?
That was the greatest payoff.
I feel like I was
just in a Hitchcock movie.
[ Laughter ]
-Because I have Letterman's --
I complimented Letterman once.
He had tassels on his loafers.
He ripped them off
and he gave them to me.
-Really?!
-But I'm gonna keep those.
-Oh, you're gonna keep
the tassels, but --
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
And Martha Stewart
is having a tag sale, also.
-Really?
-Same time I am.
Yeah, competition's on.
-Hold on.
I'm gonna sign that for you.
-And when I did
"Conan O'Brien" once, I had,
like, a wood carved squirrel,
and I turned it into, you know,
to smoke pot out of,
like a bong.
And I brought it on "Conan,"
and I handed it to Martha,
and it still had pot
in the chamber.
I'm auctioning that off.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-But she didn't ever smoke it?
You just gave it to her.
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You -- We were talking
about rabbit-sitting,
and I do want to ask.
-Okay.
-Were you -- As a younger
person, did you ever babysit?
-I was a horrible babysitter.
-Why were you horrible?
I'm surprised.
-I was real --
A minute the parents left,
I was like, "You go to bed now.
I don't care what --
You go now, right now."
And then I'd make them
go to bed.
Of course, I'd eat everything,
ransack the place.
And then I was addicted
to Barbra Streisand,
and that's back in Rona Barrett.
You know,
they had those magazines.
I would, you know, cut up
pictures of Barbra Streisand
that were in
the gossip magazines.
-So you would go
through their home --
-Ransack it.
-And you would cut out --
I mean, I would say,
there might be nothing more
haunting than dropping off
the babysitter,
coming back home, flipping
through your magazines,
and just, like, all the
Barbra Streisands are gone.
-I know. It's terrible.
-Yeah, well --
-Or I'd double-book.
I'd say yes to a lot of people
because I didn't want
to turn people down.
-That's good.
People do like to find out
at the last minute
the babysitter is not coming.
-"Yes. Sorry.
But I'm sending someone
named Rikki over."
And that never worked out.
But I wanted to talk
about this dress.
When I go shopping with David --
-Yes, that's your brother.
-My brother David.
He talked me into getting this
dress because it's unflattering.
-Okay.
-And the tulle is up here.
And one time,
I talked Dave into buying a pair
of women's slacks at Agnes B,
where it zipped up the back.
And he was at a urinal.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't want to -- So I might
auction this dress off.
-It's beautiful.
I like that dress.
I don't think it's unflattering.
-I feel like I'm pregnant.
That's what it feels like.
-I guess it doesn't look --
I see that there's
some flaws, yeah.
-Yeah, he goes, "Oh..."
-But when you walked out,
oh, my goodness. Yeah.
It was, like, up here,
and as you sat, it was like...
-I'm gonna auction it off.
Byoo-oop! Yeah. Whatever.
-I think it looks
very beautiful,
and I'm very happy
to be a part of this auction.
I'm gonna try to get you
some more stuff, as well.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Okay. I have, like, a U-Haul.
I have a lot.
You know
in "Silence of the Lambs"
when they go into
that storage unit?
-Yeah.
-That's what my house
was starting to look like.
-Right, right.
-Clutter on clutter.
Terrible.
But, yeah, it was really hard.
-Alright, well, this good.
And I'm glad that everybody --
that both diabetics
and rabbit owners
will benefit from this.
Two communities who deserve it.
Thank you for being here.
It's always such a delight.
-Oh, it went by so fast.
-It does go by so fast.
-I'm so sorry.
-It's really funny.
You knew what you were doing.
Amy Sedaris, every--
-I didn't!
-You knew!
"Girls5eva,"
streaming now on Peacock.